I know we've had a lot of questions
surrounding some of the files we provide
students like the engine the resources.
So all the work that students will
be doing will be in the app.js file,
which is, has tons of comments in it.
So make sure you read through
that first before you even start.
Mike put in sort of
comments that sort of guide you
through what you have to build.
If you haven't had a chance to look at
it I mean it just kind of gives you that
basic structure for a few things.
And then you just have to
sort of flush out the rest.
>> Yep.
We'll start with the engine.js
>> Yes.
>> So, as I mentioned,
a game is really just a flip book.
It's the process of drawing images on
top of each other, over, and over,
and It'll provide the optical
illusion of animation.
So we created this engine.js
file because we haven't taught you
anything about the canvas tag yet
really.
At this point but we do have HTML 5
canvas course which is awesome.
>> So I actually I went through that
one last night, it's a lot of fun.
>> It is a lot of fun, it's really cool.
Cameron and James did a really
good job to make that for us.
So again if you haven't had a chance
to look at the HTML 5 Canvas Course,
if you're interested
in that kind of stuff.
It's a really fun short
course that gets to us and
it took me like an hour to
have to get through it.
>> Yeah and it's a lot of fun.
It'll teach you a lot of what's
going on in this engine .js file.
But.
That's the reason this
file exists is because for the purposes
of objects oriented in JavaScript we
don't really want you to worry about
what's going on on the canvas.
So this file creates
a canvas element for you.
Puts it on the screen.
It then sets up what
we call a game loop.
Your typical game loop has
a render function which will
render everything on the screen.
Based off of various data points.
And then it'll have an update function,
which serves as updating
those data points.
>> It's like flipping
the page in our book.
>> Exactly.
So let's take your player character for
instance.
When you first start the game up, your
player character should have an X and
a Y position of where it's at, and
a sprite that tells you
what image to load.
Any time you press the up key,
we listen for that event.
And then in your player's update
function you should say ok, if the up
key is pressed, I need to decrease my x
value on that player from this to this.
The update function only
updates that property,
it's the render function that later
on says, ok now redraw everything.
And by the process of the x
property being different.
now your character is drawn
in a different location.
In the main function, you see we're
kind of playing around with dates and
times a little bit.
The reason we do that is to provide
the opportunity for smooth animation.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So everyone's computer.
Like, I don't know what
kind of computer you have.
And, you know?
If you run this on a Macbook Pro or
a Macbook Air, your computer can
process animation faster than mine,
potentially, or slower.
And so what that means is,
on your computer for every tick.
And a tick is.
The game loop.
Each time it loops we call that a tick.
So it updates and
renders and that's a tick.
If you're on a really good computer,
your ticks will be going really,
really fast.
>> Yeah.
>> And my ticks
on a slower computer might
not be going that quick.
And the way that plays itself out is
your bugs are screaming across
the screen really quick.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
mine are cruising along a little slower.
So we need a constant to smooth this
out and make sure that my ticks and
your ticks generate a same pace for
these animations.
Thankfully, time is
a pretty good constant.
So anytime you have smooth animation,
you want to multiply that animation
against the difference of the time that
the last tick ran and the current tick.
And that's what creates the smooth
animation for your bugs.
That way your bugs run just
as quickly as mine do.
>> And the variable we've defined
that as is the dt variable.
>> The engine function also
draws what we call the level.
And so that's the base layer.
If you think of kind of layering a cake.
You know the level we draw first and
then we draw all our characters,
because they're transparent PNGs.
So we can draw them
without affecting things.
So we also take care of
drawing the level for you.
You can go in and
modify this if you want to.
>> Plenty of people have made
the board wider, taller,
added their own sprites and
things like that.
>> Yeah.
It's pretty easy.
If you want to modify it you pretty
much just add a new item into the array,
a new image into the array,
and then either increase or
decrease the number of rows and
columns based on how big you wanted it.
>> Yep, and we have all the code there
to handle loading up your images.
So i guess we'll look at resources.js?
This is just an easy image loader for
you.
So loading an image in JavaScript
can kind of be an intense process.
You have to create a new image and
then you have to apply
a source attribute to it.
And if you want any events
to happen when that
image loads then you have to do
things in a different order.
It can get messy so all this does
is it handles all of that for you.
So you have a really nice helper
function called resources.get.
Anytime you call that with passing in
a URL, it will go grab that URL for
you and load it up as an image
you can use in your canvas.
One of the other benefits of this
is that we have a caching layer,
like a really simple cache built in.
So if you call resource.get an image
one hundred times, it's only going
to go build that image one time
because it knows it already has.
So it's just helps in
the memory of performance.
>> I'm going to show you the app.js
which is very important because what,
as you can see we have already
provided you with an enemy class.
So in JavaScript.
A class object or and
a function is going to look the same.
And is going to be defined the same.
same way.
So when you see variable emeny
equals function,
this is actually an enemy class and
they have given this stop's Sprite,
so Sprite is actually a keyword for
a presenting images.
So it's going to give you
the image of the enemy and
then right here you have
the update function for
the enemies as well as the render
function for the enemy.
So these are going to be the member
functions of the enemy class.
And as you can see the update
function takes a dt.
So dt parameter is to be multiplied
with the movement of the bug for
a smooth transition.
That is why we are doing it. And
It's going to be the same on all browsers
on all sort of operating system so
you don't need to worry about it and
that's why we use the parameter.
Render, is again,
going to render the bug.
And then what you're going to do is
add in the player class
similar to the enemy class.
Only that you should add in
an additional functionality in your player
class which is called checkCollisions,
because every time a bug and
a player collide you
need to reset the game.
So that is why you are going to
be using the checkCollisions function.
All the way at the end as you can see
we have a number of keys specified.
Left, right, up and down.
So these keys are going
to be an event listener.
So anytime you hold down any of
these keys, the left, right, up or
down arrows, you need to call and
handle input method.
That is going to increment or
decrement your X and
Y values for
your player depending on his movements.
So, left is going to move the player,
left and right are going to move
the player along the x-axis,
whereas up and down will move
the player along the y-axis.
So you need to define another
method called handleInput.
That is going to take in, that is going
to listen to your keyboard strokes and
are do the necessary movements.
So that's about, it would be app.js
file and do look into the rubric.
Amanda do you have any important
pointers for our students?
[LAUGH]
>> I think the most important thing
I've seen students not taking as
much time as they might need to to
just really walk through
what's already here.
I think it's really important to get
comfortable with a star-rich code, and
then recall that most of your code
is going to go into the app.js.
That's where you're going
to do most of your work.